[music]
I was a ghost. I was alone
[music] in
giving the throne. I didn't know how to
believe I was the queen that I'm meant
to be. I live two lives, tried to play
both sides, but I [music] couldn't find
my own place. Caught a black child cuz I
got too wild. But now that's how [music]
I'm getting paid. Put up your stage. I'm
[singing] going hiding now. [music] I'm
shining [crying] like a B.
We dreaming hard. We came so far now. I
believe
we're going up up up. It's our [music]
moment. You don't care. We're going to
be going to be
up without [music]
going. Golden got to be got to be
golden. Oh, I'm done hiding now. I'm
shining like a part of me.
Oh, I would take no fears, no lies. Who
will be
waited so long to break these [singing]
walls down to wake up and feel like me?
Put these patterns [singing]
all in the past now and finally live
like the girl they all see.
No more hiding. I'll be [music] shining
like I'm born to be
cuz we are hunters voices strong.
We're going [music] up without a moment.
You know, we're going to be going to
[music] be going
without
going together. So, going to be going to
be going. Oh, I'm not hiding now. I'm
shining like I'm part [music] of me.
Oh, I would I know
you were part [music] of me. You know
we're going to be going to be going.
We're going to be going to be going to
be going to be glowing [music] like
everybody. You know that it's sun time.
No fears, no
where you
[music]
>> [music]
>> Hey friends, I hope you enjoyed watching
that flow session as much as I enjoyed
making it. I'm not going to lie, that is
probably my favorite flow session that I
have done all year. So, thank goodness
I'm getting it in just under the wire.
Right. Uh, real quickly, if you enjoyed
those Orpo Pro LED contact po that I was
using in the video, I've got good news
for you. You can get a 10% discount on
them when you use the code drexfactor
with a zero instead of an O at checkout.
You can do that over at ultraoy.com.
Once again, that is drexfactor with a
zero instead of an O. Thank you so much
to Ultraoy for sponsoring this video and
giving me an excuse to go out and do
awesome flow sessions like the one you
just watched. Speaking of thank yous,
uh, I have thank yous to offer to the
friends of the channel. Big thanks to
Dark Monk, Fire Mecca, Flowfests, Flow
Toys, Pyera Light Toys, and Ultraoy for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible. You can learn more
about all these amazing companies and
the work they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that I've got done in the
description of this here video. And
finally, this video and all the videos
on this channel would not be possible
without my amazing supporters on
Patreon. In particular, I want to give a
huge shout out to my Flow patrons who
are listed on screen right now. Thank
you all so much. You rock. And if you
out there are interested in getting your
name in the credits or access to a whole
host of other awesome rewards, you can
do that by heading on over to my Patreon
at patreon.com/drexfactorpo
and signing up. You can get access to
those rewards. And even better than
that, you'll be able to help me out in
my mission of bringing po spinning and
flow arts to the whole wide world. So go
check that out. And if you dug this
video and would love to see more flow
sessions from me, I will go ahead and
include a link to a playlist of those
videos down in the description as well
as up here on screen. Thanks so much for
watching. I hope you all are having a
happy uh holiday season and happy new
year to you. Uh and I will see you with
uh new videos in the new year. Take
care, friends. I'll see you then. Peace.